bien au fond qu emmanuel macron se
heurtent du fait de son propre
scepticisme et de la résistance des
institutions représentatives classique
qui se heurte au monde politique
classique
on le voit bien donc toute sa stratégie
et une stratégie de contournement et la
réforme vigoureuse du saison c'est une
stratégie de contournement ce qui ne
veut pas obtenir des assemblées de la
république classique et il va chercher à
l'obtenir d'un cae profondément
renouvelée amaigri ayant des pouvoirs
que l'on prévoyait être les pouvoirs
plutôt de l'assemblée nationale et puis
cette stratégie du changement qui
consiste à contourner les institutions
classiques
c'est une stratégie aussi qui s'appuie
sur une interpellation directe de la
société
quand ils s'adressent ils voient bien
que les territoires résiste on l'a bien
vu au sénat
on l'a bien vu à diverses reprises sur
la sphère de la taxe d'habitation et
donc ils s'appellent il va au delà de la
représentation de ces territoires
et ils appellent en effet à ce qu'il
appelle une mobilisation des projets
reste la question que vient d'évoquer le
jeune député des vosges
la question des moyens parce que à la
fin des fa on va discuter moyens cet été
au travers en effet de la fiscalité de
la taxe d'habitation on a discuté des
moyens des collectivités territoriales
est donc là on voit c'est un discours de
projet c'est un discours presque à une
déclaration de politique générale va se
poser dans les semaines dans les heurts
dans les semaines et dans les mois qui
viennent la question des moyens que
l'état entend accorder aux collectivités
territoriales pour qu'ils puissent
pleinement exercer leur pouvoir qui
serait donc maintenant un pouvoir
essentiellement de projets